hallo herzlich willkommen in sandys welt
und herzlich willkommen im fälligen
valley das hier so ein sehr kreativer
kampflos hier wird gearbeitet gelacht
wir sind kreativ und wir entwickeln ganz
viele projekte heute möchte ich euch von
einem großen projekt erzählen und zwar
von der geschichte von manu kam aber
jetzt kommt erstmal mit reingekommen
auch pakete wir arbeiten hier auch
[Musik]
hier sind wir in unserer lounge im
silicon valley manuka ist unsere eigene
marke an da wir mittlerweile schon mehr
als zwei jahren arbeiten luca ist
gemütliche praktische und wunderschöne
kinderkleidung aber nicht nur das manuka
beschäftigt sich mit allen dingen was
das kinderherz begehrt und wirklich alle
dinge die praktisch sind bequem und
funktional für den alltäglichen bedarf
und wir haben uns hier als marke den
namen manuka ausgedacht weil man luca im
prinzip der beste honig auf der welt ist
der natürlichste hochwertigste honig und
daher kommt eben auch unser markenname
aber jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
warum macht der zelle überhaupt gerade
kinder
[Musik]
als ich meinen wir sind kann er wenn ich
verbessere wir versuchen schon immer
jeden tag die welt ein stück weit
schöner zu machen aber auch wir können
die welt nicht retten wir können nur
unseren beitrag dazu leisten und
natürlich machen wir auch fehler aber
wir versuchen trotzdem jeden tag alles
auf bestmöglichem wege zu erreichen und
wir haben einfach nur lust drauf neuer
marke zu gründen weil wir uns einfach
projekte vornehmen wir haben eine idee
und für uns ist es einfach ein teil
davon wie wir uns selbst kreativ
ausleben können deswegen haben wir
manuka gegründet einfach weil wir lust
drauf haben weil wir dafür brennen und
immer wenn wir uns vornehmen dann holen
wir uns einfach fachkräfte mit dazu wir
vergrößern unser team wir stemmen dieses
projekt zusammenarbeiten da auch dran
und möchten einfach unsere ideen
verwirklichen und im team manuka habe
ich denn da nie an meiner seite denn
dani kennt ihr vielleicht auch schon aus
der ein oder anderen story oder mal aus
einem rezept video denn immer wenn es
leckere torten und kuchen gibt dann
kommt da immer mal garrett und probiere
job hallo in der stille und den daly
haben wir kennen gelernt vor 23 jahren
über einen bekannten und man hat genau
und wir sind mittlerweile nicht nur
partner sondern auch sehr gute freunde
das heißt wir verbringen nicht nur
unseren arbeitsalltag zusammen sondern
auch die freizeit bester babysitter er
war man munkelt es dass allah und samira
mich mögen nein der spaß beiseite ich
glaube das haben wir es ganz gut
hinbekommen die letzten
monate und jahre zusammen da muss man
schon sagen turbulent war es auf jeden
fall definitiv und es war wirklich ein
sehr schwerer anfang muss ich sagen mit
manuka denn da überhaupt mal ein konzept
zu erstellen unsere ganzen werte und und
alles was wir so vermitteln wollten
unsere schwerpunkte da alles zu bündeln
eine marke zu gründen und dann textilien
zu erstellen das ist schon viel arbeit
und das geht echt nicht alleine und wir
möchten bei unserer neuen marke einfach
schwerpunkte setzen die uns besonders
wichtig sind als mama nervt es mich zum
beispiel total wenig sanierer und enger
kleidung kaufe und die kinder schon in
zwei drei wochen wieder herauswachsen
das heißt wenn zum beispiel ella in
ihrer größe schon röhrenjeans hat das
sind so dinge die ich finde bei kindern
ein bisschen überflüssig sind also eine
fünfjährige oder viel zu enge zu kurz
geschnittene kleidung weil ich finde
kinder die müssen sich frei bewegen
können die wachsen ja auch relativ
schnell dann haben sie wachstumsphasen
wo es einfach super schnell geht andere
phasen da geht's einfach ein bisschen
langsamer und ich finde es dann immer
ganz gut wenn ich einfach im frühjahr
für den sommer was einkauf und im sommer
später dann was für den winter und mir
ist es wirklich schon oft passiert dass
sich die eltern im herbst schon
winterkleidung gekauft habe und im
winter hat sie einfach nicht mehr
gepasst weil einfach alles viel zu eng
geschnitten war und dieses thema mit der
fast fashion das ist auch so ein großes
problem aber ich hatte es auch schon
ganz oft mit meiner freundin jessie die
jessy betreibt nämlich seit mehreren
jahren schon einen kids concept store in
kirrlach wir kennen uns auch schon seit
über sieben jahren sie hatte mir damals
auch für ella schon ein paar
kleidungsstücke gegeben und bei jazz im
laden ist es so man denkt vielleicht auf
den ersten blick ok die kleidung ist
nicht so günstig wie überall sonst aber
jazz liegt da einfach auch wert darauf
auf slow fashion das heißt früher gab es
zum beispiel im jahr zwei kollektionen
oder vier kollektionen einmal frühjahr
und sommer und dann herbst und winter
und mittlerweile ist es so in der fast
fashion industrie das ist wirklich jede
woche und manchmal sogar jeden tag
einfach neue kollektionen gibt und
überall in den großen ketten verfügbar
ist das heißt du kommst heute war es
morgen ist es schon wieder alt die
kleidung die wechselt einfach stetig es
wird alles immer schneller alles immer
billiger und alles sofort verfügbar und
da wollen wir einfach weg davon weil ich
mir denke als mama ich möchte ein
kleiderschrank der kinder nicht einfach
vollhauen mit dingen die in zwei drei
wochen oder monaten wieder raus
gewachsen sind und deswegen haben wir
uns gedacht machen wir das ganze wieder
ein bisschen langsamer gehen so ein
bisschen wieder zurück in die alte
kleider kultur was ich jedenfalls damit
sagen möchte man sollte die kleidung die
man kindern kauft einfach so gut kaufen
das ist eine tolle qualität hat dass man
es wirklich einmal kauft und dann dem
geschwisterkind oder anderen kindern
einfach weiter vererben kann und das
geht eben nur wenn man eine top qualität
hat einen tollen schnitt hat und eben
auch die verarbeitung und auf die
kleinen details eben auch wert legt und
die tradition mit der kinderkleidung da
bin ich schon ein bisschen stolz drauf
weil wir das in der familie auch nämlich
so weiterführen alles was samira
getragen hat hat zum beispiel auch die
greta schauen also samir als freundin
die tauschen auch immer untereinander
kleidung aus dann bekommt das ganze die
ela zu tragen ein paar jahre später wir
haben dann immer kisten die wir
beschriften und sortieren und dann kommt
das ganze in kisten rein in den schrank
nach der elbe kommt dann auch noch mal
eine freundin nämlich meine beste
freundin die nadja da bekommst dann die
kleine sophia und so wird es bei uns
auch von generation zu generation von
haushalt zu haushalt einfach
weitergegeben das geht natürlich nur
wenn es qualitativ hochwertige kleidung
ist und worauf wir auch wert gelegt
haben beim anuga ist folgendes es gibt
der kleidungsstücke auch gerade in
großkonzernen die sind einfach jetzt
momentan im trend das heißt pepa wurzel
sah die ganzen disney figuren und es ist
ja immer ganz schön die kinder stehen
drauf aber was da halt relativ schade
ist und es sich bei ela momentan sehr
heller hat dann so ihren eigenen kopf
und erträgen und das was sie schön
findet und was eben auch cool findet und
wenn ich eher zum vierten geburtstag war
es von papa wutz gekauft habt ist es ein
halbes jahr später schon wieder out das
heißt beim anuga wollen wir auch darauf
verzichten dass wir einfach modetrends
die heute in sind mit draufdrücken das
lassen wir ganz bewusst weg damit die
kleidung eben auch noch in fünf zehn
oder 15 jahren top aktuell ist und das
kind nicht merken kann das ist
eigentlich mehr gefällt ja nie wissen
wir sind immer bestrebt unsere region
mit zu unterstützen das heißt auch für
uns für manuka möchten wir unsere kinder
kleidung in germany also in deutschland
herstellen und das ganze war hatte
hamdani so ein bisschen raus und
waschechter schwabe er kann nichts dafür
wir mögen ihn trotzdem moralische
aufgabe aber wir haben dann mit den
partnern immer so einen also wir baten
daher mit den schwaben kein problem mit
der vergangenheit
und deswegen kommt unsere kleidung
tatsächlich auch aus der stuttgarter
region richtig aus pfullingen am fuße
der schwäbischen alb vom lieben dennis
fischer ist unser produzent aber es ist
nicht nur der dennis fischer der
natürlich in die produktion involviert
ist es sind auch andere betriebe zum
spiel dazu schnitt erfolgt in albstadt
dann haben wir den steg und den druck
der dann in burladingen gemacht wird
alle fäden führen natürlich dann nach
pfullingen zum trotz wird alles zusammen
ernährungs praktisch mit seinem team die
kleidung nämlich zusammen und anfangs
ist es einfach so dass unsere stoffe die
werden eben für uns gelebt gefärbt und
dann kommen sie zum zuschnitt und dort
werden alle musterteile praktisch
geschnitten alle die ganze kollektion
das heißt unsere ots unsere hosen die
kleider die röcke da wird alles schön
zugeschnitten kommt dann wiederum zum
stück und dort wird dann unser stück
drauf gemacht die einzelteile werden
eben gefertigt und kommen dann sozusagen
als raw ware direkt zum dennis genug und
denn es hat da seine fachkräfte dineen
dort vor ort und es ist wirklich
schwierig muss man sagen mittlerweile in
deutschland überhaupt näher und
näherinnen zu finden unter dennis auch
wirklich bestrebt immer mehr fachkräfte
zu finden das heißt wenn ihr näher oder
näheren seit aus dem raum stuttgart
bohlingen dann könnt ihr euch bei
jederzeit bewerben der denner sucht
immer am fachkräfte die noch weiter
hinaus helfen können und sollen cafés
exzellent
deswegen also wirklich kinderkleidung
nicht von kindern gemacht sondern von
erwachsenen für kinder und aus der
produktion beim dennis kommst dann
sozusagen direkt zu uns auf lager und
wird bei uns dann verpackt und versendet
richtig ja aber jetzt wollen wir euch
einfach mal unsere kollektion auch
zeigen und euch die ganzen details
zeigen also genau worauf er wert gelegt
haben also ich glaube mitunter natürlich
das wichtigste ist das material ist
grundmaterial wir haben darauf geachtet
dass wir einfach einen sehr hochwertigen
stoff verwenden ja bedeutet einfach dass
man ein langlebiges material hat es die
kiddies einfach austoben können dass sie
spielen können und dass das ganze
einfach robust ist er bringt ein neues
von generation zu generation war selten
können genau
wir haben lange gehirn für saßen oft
zusammen hätten gesagt wo können wir uns
unterscheiden wenn wir einfach basic
ware machen ja und wir haben natürlich
schon gesagt okay es müssen die
kleinigkeiten sein die dann einfach
schlussendlich unserem alter kleidung
einzigartig machen ja nach schöne
schnitte gute passform dass die kinder
aber auch nicht zu schnell herauswachsen
und eine figurbetonte kleidung bleibt
weil das muss bei kindern halt echt nett
sein aber sie muss trotzdem schick
aussehen bequem seien die kinder sollen
toben können und das macht eigentlich
unsere kleidung aus dass auch langlebig
und robust qualitativ hochwertiges aber
trotzdem schick richtig und natürlich
die tollen kleinen details man sie zum
beispiel das stück an der tasche was
natürlich auch noch so ein ganz tolles
highlight ist ich kann noch von früher
wie taschen bei den hosen egal ob kurz
oder lang das unterstellen kastanien
seien kein billiger ich weiß nicht was
man danach immer mit ihnen gemacht hat
aber man hat sie gesammelt gefasst und
die bastel ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen
so von der ersten idee bis zu den
fertigen teilen ist das wirklich ein
langer weg was wir euch jetzt erspart
haben waren sozusagen die ganzen
fittings das heißt die ersten teile
kommen zu uns wenn sie ausprobiert auch
mal gewaschen wie sich zum beispiel der
pulli der hude die röcke verhalten beim
waschen beim trocknen die kinder dürfen
zimmer anprobieren wir haben die
schnitte optimiert sodass wirklich auch
für jeden körper chip was dabei ist und
die schnitte bestmöglich auch wirklich
jedem passen wir haben geschaut ob die
ärmel lang genug sind aber eben auch
nicht zu lange dass sie zum beispiel
kinder stören ob die nähte gut
verarbeitet sind auch die taschen tief
genug sind und jetzt sind wir wirklich
so weit dass die ersten fertigen
musterteile da sind und die kinder
defensiv einfach mal ausprobieren
austesten und anziehen beim ersten
fotoshooting
[Musik]
in dubai
ok
gemeint sind
[Musik]
fans und nimmst du nie
[Applaus]
vittorio
colao
[Musik]
ganz links tun
zeigt uns wie wir
ja und das ist unsere kollektion wir
werden euch später das ganze auch noch
als richtig tolle modenschau
präsentieren aber dazu kommen wir später
ja wir betrachten ja alles immer relativ
ganzheitlich das heißt wir haben jetzt
hier kinderkleidung aber ihr seht auch
schon unter der woche
erwachsenenkleidung denn so eine mini
collection wenn die tochter des anhalt
willst die mama oder oma opa oder onkel
daniel der dann auch stylisch passend
mit der elle auch ein spielplatz geben
kann und da wir alles ganzheitlich
betrachten ist bei uns hört bei uns eben
auch nicht bei der kleidung auf sondern
wir haben uns auch überlegt lasst doch
alles machen was uns im alltag
beschäftigt alles was kinderherzen höher
schlagen lässt und wir waren wie immer
kreativ ja ich glaube es sind super
ideen entstanden die reise von manuchehr
beginnt hier erst so viel können wir
schon jetzt verraten
aber wenn ich alleine nein das haben wir
uns natürlich auf die fahne geschrieben
und dann haben wir junge kreative
menschen rekrutiert von der hochschule
in pforzheim und mit denen zusammen
haben wir was richtig cooles auf die
beine gestellt und ich würde sagen die
stellen wir euch jetzt mal was auf jeden
fall
[Musik]
und wir haben ja gesagt der ist
spielzeug soll von von menschen mit
einer beeinträchtigung seiner
behinderung gemacht werden das ist für
diese menschen live zu produzieren weil
weil es ist wirklich komplett einfarbig
und jetzt gibst du jemanden menschen so
ein ding und sagt komm mal an und zieht
daran so ein perfektes wie genial ist
dass die geschichte eigentlich wirklich
schön also dass es trotzdem was
unterstellen müsste sollte also ist echt
cool was
[Musik]
caro ich könnte jetzt auch an den dingen
lecken jetzt wird nichts passieren
mit bienenwachs eingelassen
kohl das ist eine coole geschichte
und hier sieht man auch mit pins
frischen charaktere geben kann genau und
auch hier wieder der focus diese
natürlichkeit von dem holz durch
einzulassen die pins nicht komplett
komplett zu machen sondern auch teile
holz fallen zu lassen
[Musik]
und damit man bei der produktion darauf
achten wirklich mein produkt zu
erschaffen wo aus wenn es möglich ist
wir versuchen immer das bestmögliche
komplett aus einem material
[Musik]
und wir haben auch keine fast fashion
bei fast fashion ist gerade im trend
momentan kennen sie doch meistens die
neue im trend da sind irgendwelche tiere
im trend deshalb kein trends seien das
heißt so etwas sein wo ich immer modul
event geraten freund ich stelle mir die
patches macht sie drauf aber im grunde
genommen bleibt der rucksack immer
gleich
[Musik]
ach das ist ja genial kann man das ist
genau das kann man forschen dass es aus
deiner feder entsprungen ist das war
design richtig cool lässt ihn einfach
rausziehen und dann nicht als er klar
das kommt jetzt blöd ein bisschen bei
mir auch noch
eine rechteckige form heißt der größte
mögliche platz wenn wir hier eine
rundung drin hätten dann hätte ich ein
problem mit dem platz und da müssen sich
einschränken aber denn die haben den
idealen platz mit einem mit einem
rechtlich geschaffen ja richtig gehen ja
wirklich ein so dass man begeistert
gerade mehrere funktionen eine
nachhaltigkeit gedacht und vor allem im
zweiten drittel nutzen und was auch
nochmal toll ist diesen rucksack auch
weiterzugeben das heißt qualität so weit
ist es extrem wichtig
[Musik]
gern ein großer bestandteil beim anuga
ist unser kinderspielzeug und da haben
wir uns jetzt erst mal vorgenommen
kinderspielzeug zu machen was total
naturbelassen ist das heißt zuerst aber
holzspielzeug machen in verschiedenen
formen verschiedenen farben alles
speichel und spricht damit die kinder
das eben auch meinen mund nehmen können
was sie sowieso den ganzen tag tun und
hier haben wir uns gedacht machen wir
einfach kinderspielzeug in einer
werkstatt wo menschen arbeiten mit
trisomie 21 also mit dem down syndrom
und hier ist es aber wirklich so dass
wir das nicht machen weil es günstiger
ist in der herstellung sondern zum einen
der soziale aspekt diese menschen sind
alles ganz normale menschen sind ganz
besondere menschen mit tollen
fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten und diese
menschen werden komplett normal bezahlt
wie jeder andere arbeitnehmer auch das
heißt es nicht billiger und günstiger
hergestellt sondern einfach gleich viel
wert und es ist uns auch sehr wichtig
weil nämlich jeder mensch seinen
lebensunterhalt finanzieren muss und
bezahlen muss und wir uns da eben
vorgenommen haben das genauso zu machen
und jetzt haben wir hier unser spielzeug
team und ihr könnt ja mal erzählen was
unser spielzeug so besonders macht weil
ich mein spielzeug gibt es ja schon in
hülle und fülle
als mama weiß man auch spielzeug wird
ständig aussortiert weil einfach viel zu
viel davon da ist es ist wirklich eine
reizüberflutung an allem aber ich mag
zum beispiel ganz gerne montessori
spielzeug wo die kinder einfach auch
noch was anfassen verschiedene formen
verschiedene farben das ganze haptische
mit dabei und da haben uns das gut
überlegt genau gerade auch bei
montessori spielzeug oder lernspielzeug
ist es schön dass die kinder nicht nur
was zum spielen haben sondern einfach
spielerisch lernen wir haben jetzt hier
zum beispiel das hat dieser designt eine
murmelbahn und das besondere an dieser
nur mit bahn ist einfach das ist
auseinander bar ist zwar wie eine
herkömmliche murmelbahn aber du kannst
die seiten auch umdrehen also du hast
mehr als nur eine möglichkeit die hier
eine spielatmosphäre spielebene zu bauen
und
dann das ganze durch das labyrinth die
murmel zu führen
das ist eine idee wie man das ganze
umsetzen kann aber der hat ja auch hier
noch eine andere möglichkeit genau wir
haben ja noch ein balance spiel das die
feinmotorik von den kindern so ein
bisschen
das dies so ein bisschen erlernen und
das selbst für erwachsene schwierig hier
teile drauf zu starten weil sobald man
einen teil neu aufsetzt und dann ein
bisschen falsch auf selbst vielleicht
kann es auch sehr gut
lernspielzeug für kleine und große
kinder
noch das war hier lernt das sondern auch
vielleicht etwas hat also ein
designobjekt das einfach nicht
unterschreiben kann die eröffnung ist
launisch wie
schön alles in farbe die wird dann noch
auswählen so ein bisschen auf die manuka
farben auf die man haben genau die
kleidung abgestimmt dann her um die neue
kollektion kommt wird vielleicht das
neue spielzeug auch darauf abgestimmt
das ist einfach ein einheitliches
konzept ich habe mir frage ich hatte als
kind ein lieblingsspielzeug es war so
eine holzeisenbahn und die vordere lok
war immer in form von einem löwen es war
ein absolutes lieblings spielzeug wären
wir auch mit euch darüber gesprochen so
ein stück weit wie können wenn man auch
so ein bisschen dieses charakterliche
spielzeug herausarbeiten und ich finde
da könnt ihr vielleicht schon so ein
kleiner einblick geben charakter
spielzeugen ist es ja das schöne einfach
dass das kind einen bezug zu seinem
spielzeug ausleben kann eine emotionale
bindung einfach eingeht und das dann
sozusagen direkt hier ist das besondere
ist dass hier die hacker hier die zacken
die vom dinosaurier sind die sind
stecker und können sozusagen außen
ausgetauscht werden hier ist es zum
beispiel eine maus und die geht dann mit
dem dino auf eine reise und mit dem kind
zusammen und dazu gibt es natürlich dann
immer auch kleine geschichte damit man
dann auch also die geschichte dann zum
beispiel mit dino und der maus oder halt
dann auch vielleicht ein anderes thema
passt da auch ganz schön wär ich hatte
in meiner zeit ihr als
grundschullehrerin hatte ich immer
unterrichtsmaterial selber gemacht das
heißt geschichten geschrieben
bilderbücher gemalt unterrichtsmaterial
gemacht und da können wir uns auch
überlegen ob wir dann nicht geschichten
schreiben ich habe da meine beste
freundin die nadja die war immer so
meine geschichtenerzählerin und wenn man
die geschichten gemacht ich hab sie
gemalt und dann kann man vielleicht auch
zum spielzeug dazu immer lesebücher
vorlesebücher machen das ist glaube ich
dann haben wir sowas komplett des
schönes wo man einfach auch viel dabei
lernen kann ja über vielleicht auch
geschwisterkinder so eine sanierer der
etwas vorliest oder auch erstlesebücher
oder und die kinder selber anfangen
können ja und ich glaube deswegen
versteht ihr jetzt auch warum man o cara
mia und unser besonders am herzen liegt
denn ich muss sagen hierfür ich meinem
bildungsauftrag immer noch weiter fort
das heißt ich habe einmal geschaut ich
setze mich mit meinem besten wissen und
gewissen dafür einen wissen weiter zu
geben und das machen wir hier auch das
heißt wir machen jetzt hier nicht nur
kleidung sondern auch spielzeug womit
man auch ganz toll lernen kann
spielerisch die kinder fördern und
fordern kann was er wirklich sehr
wichtig ist im alltag vor allem wenn
alle erziehungsberechtigten auch
vollzeit oder teilzeit berufstätig sind
muss man schon immer schauen dass man zu
hause finde ich eher negatives spielzeug
hat deswegen das ist schon mal ein
kleiner einblick aber wir haben auch
eine überraschung für unsere studenten
die holen wir eben mal daniel okay denn
heute überraschen wir euch
ein paar einblicke habt ihr schon
bekommen in die werke der studenten der
hochschule pforzheim der fakultät
gestaltung und da wurde schon kreiert
gezeichnet modelliert gebaut gebastelt
und ich habe jetzt hier schon das erste
muster stück in meiner hand als
überraschung und wird die studenten da
drin war damit überraschen ich kann
jetzt mal so viel verraten wir haben
keine
mühen gescheut und auch vielleicht
kosten wir haben das erste muster
als überraschung gereicht
und für euch zu hause habe ich auch eine
überraschung denn jetzt geht es direkt
nach kerl 18 jesse zur kindermodenschau
dann würde ich sagen wie cool oder
design und wie schön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt sind wir hier in kirrlach bei
unserer freundin jessie bei emi und
greta die jesse ist eine langjährige
freundin von uns und ich kenne sie auch
schon seit 2005 10 seit 2013 hat sie
hier ihren kids concept store das
bedeutet alles was kinder und teenager
glücklich macht babys natürlich auch
unterlagen bei ihr heißt eben und greta
benannt nach ihren zwei kindern emil und
greta und die jessy muss man sagen die
hat einfach ein know how sie hat die
fachkompetenz und ich bin auch echt froh
dass wir sie als freundin haben denn als
wir mit unserer idee auf sie zugekommen
sind hc uns natürlich sehr unterstützt
muss man sagen auf jeden fall und sie
hat uns auf jeden fall mit ihrem
know-how unterstützt sie natürlich
tagtäglich in ihren stars anwendet die
gespräche mit den kunden sie sieht die
kids jeden tag in kleidung und konnte
und sich an der ein- oder anstelle auch
mal einen guten tipp geben wo wir gesagt
haben vielen dank bauen wir mit ein also
nicht nur als mama sondern wie gesagt
doch alles perfekt als beraterin ja und
die tests sie war zum glück schon ganz
früh manuka auch mit dabei mit ihrer
fachkompetenz mit ihrem know how denn
sie weiß natürlich auch was man muss ein
paar was brauchen oder onkel und tanten
denn die sind ja wirklich tagtäglich
hierbei eher und fühlen mit ihr
beratungsgespräche und die achtet auch
auf die kleinigkeiten wie zum beispiel
ich warte auch schon mit dabei dass
jemand ein baby geschenk kaufen wollte
und dann sagt sie okay besuch so die
person gleich oder erst in drei monaten
weil bis dahin sechs ist kind schon
wieder raus es sind einfach dinge als
alltägliche dinge aus der praxis die sie
mit einfließen lässt und jetzt finde ich
echt froh mein opa ist jetzt praktisch
gelaunt und ich bin sehr happy weil die
letzten zwei jahre doch ziemlich
intensiv waren wirklich sagen und ich
muss auch sagen es macht mich sehr stolz
ich meine jazz laden hier ist
normalerweise auch schon immer voll aber
jetzt haben wir wirklich zum kompletten
laden voll ausgestattet mit unserer
valluga ware mit der kleidung fing es an
aber damit hat es ja auch nicht auf wir
haben ja auch unser kinderspielzeug was
noch kommen wird unser rucksack dafür
den kindergärten der rucksack für die
schule und dann sogar noch eine kosmetik
anteil wir arbeiten eine kinder kosmetik
weil ich finde
das haben wir auch schon öfter jetzt
gesagt dass sie alles immer ganzheitlich
betrachten und wirklich alles so
komplett einfach mit ausstaffieren von
jetzt wird eine tolle mama will auf
jeden fall und jetzt haben wir uns
gedacht als krönenden abschluss nicht
nur für uns sondern auch für die kinder
hier möchten wir jetzt eine schöne
kleine kindermodenschau machen mit den
eltern mit den familien einfach hier
ganz schnuckelig bei emil und kreta
deswegen fiel vielen dank fürs
einschalten auch von meiner stelle
vielen vielen dank danke auch vielen
live chat und habe viel spaß bei der
kinder wurden schaut mit palucca ich
freue mich jetzt schon drauf weil ich
meine wir sind jetzt eine
kindermodenschau profis das machen wir
jetzt einfach so neben pro visieren wir
im jahr daher wird es trotzdem war sie
laufen so zwei drei mal und ich meine
das von der nur schwachen die us
wirtschaft ist mit komm lass dich holen
wir sind hier draußen kommt rein
[Musik]
ja jetzt immer drei monate später und es
hat sich ein bisschen was verändert muss
ich sagen in der zwischenzeit hat
nämlich die jf tatsächlich beschlossen
ihren süßen und väter laden zu schließen
nach zehn jahren
da bin ich sehr traurig drücke ich
eigentlich auch
erzählt du ja der mietvertrag läuft aus
und die letzten zwei jahre waren für den
einzelhandel einfach sehr hart und nach
zehn jahren ist manchmal auch zeit
loszulassen die kinder sind jetzt groß
immer nur kreta sind groß und ja zeit
das letzte kapitel zu beenden und ein
neues buch zu öffnen ja das ganze ging
jetzt tatsächlich doch recht schnell
und deswegen hat hier jetzt auch schon
der ausverkauf gestartet und ich muss
mich sehr bemühen nicht zu emotional
nicht versprach erreichte weinen
und ja das heißt das quasi so in den
nächsten ein zwei wochen der laden
geschlossen wird aber wir haben uns
überlegt dass wir ab morgen also ab
samstag sozusagen unsere manuka ware
auch schon vier ausstellen werden für
eine woche genau und dann schließen die
türen
dietrich wir sind ja ganz gut befreundet
und
deswegen nicht weiter stützen sind manu
katché
nicht weit genug geht da gibt es ja auch
noch da sind die kinder von jesse nur
den laden gibt es dann nicht mehr
aber man geht ja es gibt es musik
unterwegs ins team und
bringt
[Musik]